[Musica]
la parte più difficile di un talk e
parlare della propria storia scavare nel
proprio passato alla ricerca di quelle
motivazioni profonde che ci spingono ad
agire ogni giorno che quelle motivazioni
profonde che determinano le nostre
decisioni e che fanno le nostre passioni
tale
diciamo che io questa mia ricerca l'ho
fatta e the inizia ed è iniziata questa
mia passione per la chimica con un
desiderio un piccolo sogno nel cassetto
era quello di fare un mago un po me ne
vergogno però perché volevo fare il mago
volevo fare il mago perché volevo
sorprendere la gente
volevo sorprenderla con qualcosa di
inaspettato unico e originale
vi sono però presto reso conto che
comunque non serve alcuna bacchetta
magica alcuna magia per sorprendere la
gente ed è così che quindi piano piano
ho imparato che si possa sorprendere la
gente anche con la scienza è quello che
ho fatto negli ultimi cinque anni della
mia vita
cinque anni in cui mi sono saltato circa
500 ore di interrogazioni per per andare
in laboratorio cosa facevo il
laboratorio oltre a cercare di fuggire
dal mio terrore che la filosofia sono mi
sono impegnato nei cosiddetti open day
gli open day sono degli eventi in cui la
scuola si autopromuove quindi immaginate
frotte di bambini che entrano ed escono
dalla scuola
il mio posto è naturalmente nel
laboratorio e ed è lì che quindi mi sono
reso conto di quanto sia importante e
soddisfacente sorprendere una persona
vedere la faccia di un volto di un
bambino spararti questo sorriso dal
nulla dalla più completa
magari noia o tristezza alla semplice
variazione più semplice variazione di
colore da una soddisfazione immensa
un giorno però alla fine di un open day
dopo aver spiegato presentato reazioni
chimiche a circa credo 1.200 ragazzi mi
sono seduto sulla su una sedia stremato
e ho deciso di fare un esperimento
diverso dal solito mi sono guardato
attorno semplicemente e dell esperimento
che vorrei fare con voi oggi voglio
provare a ridefinire la chimica quindi a
liberare la chimica da quella gabbia che
è costituita dalla sua definizione ossia
la scienza che studia le trasformazioni
della materia la chimica non è solo
questo e del mio obiettivo di questa
sera ora avrei bisogno che però che
tutti facciate una cosa ho bisogno che
tutti voi chiudiate gli occhi chiudete
respirate espirate cercate di ricordarvi
quali i periodi di quando aveva il
periodo di quando eravate bambini un
periodo spensierato in cui non c'era la
preoccupazione di andare al lavoro di
scarrozzare figli se ne avete in
macchina c'erano i vostri genitori
apportarvi per tu dove volevate adesso
riaprite gli occhi e guardatevi attorno
cosa vedete amici parenti conoscenti
gente che forse oggi avete visto per la
prima volta me compreso
ma non è solo questo vero ci sono anche
sedie palloncini travi d'acciaio metri
di colori ecco vi sembrerà strano ma se
anziché guardare osservasse quello che
vi circonda
potreste verificare potreste trovare una
connessione tra tutto quello che vedete
tra voi è tutto quello che trovate
attorno e questo tavolo è tutto chimica
pensateci bene
non so adesso avete già mangiato quindi
se avete ancora nel caso in cui veste
ancora fame quella e chimica
oppure se avete magari un po di sete per
dire l'acqua che voi bevete non è altro
che chimica
ecco però oppure anche ad esempio
potrebbe diciamo che gli esempi sono
infiniti una reazione una delle reazioni
più complesse però è l'amore pensateci
quelle farfalle nello stomaco quella
meno riuscite più a pensare a nulla non
riuscite a spiccicare bocca davanti alla
persona amata
in quel momento in voi stanno avvenendo
migliaia di reazioni chimiche in
contemporanea
forse una sede una sequenza di reazioni
chimiche tanto complesse da non poter
essere studiato a tutti gli effetti il
che spiegherebbe anche perché io non mi
sia ancora trovato una ragazza nella mia
vita quindi
ora però non pensate che questo sia
partito negli ul nell'ultimo secolo è un
questo che sto dicendo questo modo di
vedere il mondo questo modo di os di
guardarci attorno
con questo filtro davanti agli occhi che
è la chimica è il frutto di un percorso
evolutivo iniziato 2 milioni e 500 mila
anni fa
sto parlando quindi del periodo più o
meno del paleolitico
diciamo che l'uomo primitivo
per quanto si possa appunto considerare
primitivo in realtà fece una delle più
grandiose scoperte della storia
dell'umanità
una scoperta che forse noi oggi diamo
per scontata ma che al suo tempo poteva
fare la differenza tra la vita e la
morte
guardando questa scatola di fiammiferi o
ma avete già capito che sto parlando
della scoperta del fuoco riusciti
immaginare una società senza il fuoco è
semplice
togliete qualsiasi rivoluzione
industriale rivoluzione dei materiali
rivoluzione dei trasporti
togliete vestiti che avete addosso
perdete le sedie su cui siete seduti
togliete tutto quello che vedete è
sostituitelo con la pietra saremo fermi
all'età della pietra
senza la scoperta del fuoco però
naturalmente non possiamo considerare
quell'uomo già un chimico era infatti un
uomo spaventato dalla realtà che lo
circondava non riusciva a comprendere
bene il ai fenomeni della natura ed è
per questo quindi che la sua mente che
con evolvendosi inizia ad essere turbata
da degli interrogativi quali chi sono io
da dove vengo
qual è il mio scopo al mondo perché la
natura funziona così ecco che viene
forgiato quel concetto di divino vengono
forgiate vengono create migliaia e
migliaia di miti e leggende su dei figli
di dei gd day possiamo fare tutta la
parentela degli dei
però ecco che la nella grecia del quinto
secolo avanti cristo un filosofo di nome
democrito colui che il mondo a caso pone
ebbe un'intuizione geniale osservando
infatti il pulviscolo atmosferico quella
polvere sospesa nell'aria attraverso i
raggi del sole ipotizzò un mondo
costituito da tommy nel quinto secolo
avanti cristo cioè non mi risulta che
avessero rivelatori di particelle o cose
simili
quindi lasciamo stare ecco quindi potete
immaginare per questa è una
dimostrazione della potenza
dell'intelletto umano democrito le sue
teorie verranno pero sbeffeggiate nel
corso dei secoli è soprattutto dai suoi
contemporanei che erano ancora legati a
quel concetto di divino le sue ricerche
lavoro dei suoi studi verranno però
ripresi nel xvii secolo dagli alchimisti
i primi veri chimici della storia e
posso parlare di primi veri chimici per
che adottavano il metodo scientifico
osservavano teorizzavano e
sperimentavano certo non avranno trovato
il metodo per trasmutare il piombo in
oro non avranno trovato che sola la
pietra la pietra filosofale
ma ecco hanno scoperto
certe volte casualmente certe volte
intenzionalmente tutti gli elementi
della tavola periodica tutti gli
elementi che costituiscono noi e il
mondo che ci circonda tutti quegli
elementi che consentono a me di essere
in piedi qui su questo palco a parlarvi
di chimica ora questa concezione di
chimica come vi ho già detto non si può
imparare sui libri la chimica infatti
rimarrà per i libri di testo sempre
quella scienza che studia le
trasformazioni della materia o tra i
giovani quella scienza che ti permette
di fare milioni vendendo metanfetamina
come nella serie tv breaking bad
ecco questa concezione di chimica invece
come filo conduttore della storia ci ci
appare chiara solo quando facciamo un
esperimento in prima persona quando
iniziamo a sostituire alla domanda che
cosa è questo che cos'è quello la
domanda perché succede questo
perché succede quello perché la natura
funziona così ora quando uscirete da
quella porta quando entrerete nelle
vostre macchine quando arriverete nelle
vostre case
fermatevi guardatevi attorno come
farebbe un bambino lasciatevi
sorprendere anche dalla cosa più più
scontata e vi si aprirà un mondo di
meraviglie
ora il bello di questo paese dei
balocchi come mi piace definirlo e che
non esiste limite non esiste limite
perché tutto chimica tutto può essere
ridotto ad una semplice equazione
chimica quindi non esiste più il
concetto di assurdo non esiste più il
concetto di impossibile ma invece viene
introdotto il concetto di tutto è
possibile basta fare una semplice cosa
bastava comportarsi un po come gli
alchimisti basta semplicemente quindi
osservare teorizzare
e sperimentare non va bene grazie
[Applauso]